tout de suite retrouvez l'actualité de
la semaine retour en images les
principaux événements du département
le réseau car jaune a fêté ses 20 ans au
jardin de l'état soutient la mise à nu
quand vous rendez à la manquer c'est un
village village festif pour cette
journée pour ses 20 ans car jaune donc
on commence avec une exposition qui
retrace toute l'histoire du transport
mais surtout du car jaune de la
naissance en 1996 à aujourd'hui donc
ce village aux jeux lontan a mis toute
la famille dans une ambiance de partage
intergénérationnel du quart courants
d'air ou nouveaux véhicules à étages
c'est la même génération de voyageurs
sans lutter 55,71 séquence est d'accord
la verve en défense j'ai couché on prend
le bus que sa vie oui et puis c c'est
une autre chose on ne touche plus le
même public
le réseau évolué le réseau est devenu
moderne performant nous voulons qu'il
soit encore plus attractif pour
justement pallier à deux problématiques
la problématique du tout voiture et l'a
promis dé la problématique de
l'engagement routier plus de 5 millions
de voyageurs par an près de 8 millions
de kilomètres parcourus dans l'île
170 conducteurs 139 arrêt le car jaune
est partout
la journée des aidants s'est déroulée ce
jeudi 6 octobre au village corail à
saint gilles un moment de détente et de
partage 3 aidants familiaux qui s'occupe
au quotidien de personnes âgées ou
handicapées pour avoir visité donc pas
mal de grammont pas ce que je fais ça
toutes les semaines je visite les
gramounes je vois vraiment le travail
que font ces aidants et c'est pour ça
que je soutiens le gps ap qui porte
cette journée aujourd'hui et j'espère
que tous les ans il y aura une journée
dédiée aux aidants et le mérite
fortement cette journée c'est une
journée de rencontres d'information et
de partage entre les aidants et les
professionnels on a démarré avec une
conférence donc une conférence qui est
animé donc par monsieur match et le
gardon de l'association française des
aidants et suivra cette conférence
divers ateliers de bien-être et des
stands d'information presse avide de
carrément s'était passé une très bonne
journée bien organisée sa famille fait
plaisir
dans la vie une journée de détente et de
partage en soutien aux aidants familiaux
grâce à qui le maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées et handicapées est
possible
colloque sur les 70 ans de la
départementalisation s'est déroulée
cette semaine dans l'hémicycle du
conseil départemental mieux comprendre
les enjeux soixante dix ans après la loi
de 1946 et différents partenaires ont
posé les axes de ce développement
d'après la période coloniale
un développement qui a permis de
construire une égalité entre le
territoire français et la réunion
grand témoin de ce colloque paul vergès
albert ramassamy et jean paul virapoullé
figure politique locale qui se sont
battus pour cette départementalisation
pour avoir leur légalité charles il a
fallu attendre 50 ans
et pour l'obtenir il a fallu que les
waro et moi-même quand nous étions
dégoûté
nous avons publiquement démissionner
suzanne en disant nous ne resterons plus
dans cette assemblée de temps qu'on
n'oublie pas
ceva content a eu mais 50 ans après la
départementalisation a fait de nous des
professeurs du proviseur nous a apporté
ce qui était nécessaire à l'évolution
indispensable à notre transformation
c'est à dire l'apport de l'éducation
aujourd'hui la départementalisation d'un
support pour faire de la réunion un
exemple dans l'océan indien
nous avons la chance d'avoir deux câbles
d'un meuble jeu
l'europe et la france avec ses deux
atouts majeurs allons bosser allons
transpirer allons pas plaint nous allons
construire l'avenir
l'avenir c'est l'éducation la formation
et l'équipement du pays
l'ouverture au monde la rentrée dans la
mondialisation et nous pouvons le faire
parce que nous sommes département
français et régions ultra périphériques
de l'europe gouvernance développement
humain économie emploi et surtout
quelles perspectives pour demain le
colloque des 70 ans ouvre des champs à
explorer mais surtout des solutions à
trouver pour que la réunion inscrive son
développement humain et économique étend
son territoire
océan indien dans la france dans
l'europe mais également dans le monde
la programmation des théâtres
départementaux pour novembre et décembre
on commence à partir du 23 novembre ici
et théâtre champfleury avec la compagnie
xy si nous compagnie tirkel à 24
circassiens du plateau et médias ou la
fille doit d'un franchement ils sont
partout pour partir donc c'est vraiment
un spectacle extraordinaire at-il fait
200 dates dans le monde entier on a la
chance continue grâce à la réunion
après nous continuer à ce même d'après
avec la musique classique avec la garde
républicaine d'un réunionnais dedans qui
joue de la contrebasse très beau
programme avec deux musiciens qui jouent
du violon contrebasse tout ça mozart
tchaïkovski britten est le gard où nos
très belle musique classique
ensuite nous n'aura fred espel ça c'est
en décembre et fred espel peut-être de
monicault n'est pas vraiment que ça
allait mais c'est une personne n'a écrit
les plus belles musiques de la réunion
et comme pas un petit case en paille et
sue plateau ban aura taton tacon
d'artistes la réunion comme stéphanie
thazar part de ma génération
nicole dambreville d'attaché à tord
thiam si jacqueline farreyrol jean-marc
que nous a mis à marie armande et henri
claude moutou ils y apprennent à une
résidence de los griot que fils de
daniel sami pageaux qui aube à damier et
là ça serait une restitution pour
discuter avec eux pour écouter un peu
leur nouvel univers et une exposition au
théâtre champ fleuri avec la cité
d'architecturé de paris sur comment
réenchanter le monde ratée rod janois un
peu sûr que ça il veut dire
l'architecturé jona